it's about two hours for me
they bled they fell over they tore
muscles one actor even nearly got sick
on set because of their costume the
bridgerton cast went through it filming
their second season of the netflix hit
we're going behind the scenes to check
out just how painful the bridgerton
beauty treatment was
number one has anyone ever really liked
wearing a corset you must know it has
weighed on me every day simone ashley
joins a long long line of actors who
endure the hardships of corset wearing
which unfortunately includes injuries
ranging from scratches to torn muscles
she's been pretty honest about her
experience while filming explaining i
had a lot of pain with a corset too i
think i tore my shoulder at one point
not only was it painful but the
accessory made doing basic tasks more
difficult as well
in the actress's own words because when
you're in a corset you can't put your
shoes on there were a few scenes where
it was a bit
couldn't lift my arms up couldn't you
know embrace us her co-star nicola
coughlin wasn't wrong when she suggested
there be corsetry acting awards given to
every single actress in the show wearing
one just for getting through filming
number two league struggles are real
struggles
penelope's hair is so big because it's
so full of secrets it's big hair and
apparently unpredictable at times as
well nicola coughlin has a massive wig
which also means it's a pretty weighty
accessory to carry around on top of your
head
not to mention the added struggle of the
tiara when she sports it glamour is pain
one of the biggest struggles of wearing
such a big wig though is losing parts of
it without even noticing the actress
would be minding her own business when
suddenly a voice from the set would ask
did someone lose a curl bits of penelope
featherington's hair were lost all
around the set just another regency
aerodrama issue to worry about
number three the costumes cost and
weighed pounds all those crinolines and
layers make for weighty costumes but
simone ashley had a particularly heavy
wardrobe well by the end of the series
she had a bit of an easier time moving
around in more lightweight costumes off
the top of the season was a real
struggle because of the high quality but
heavy silks and taffetas used to help
show the closed offness of her character
early on in the show the costumes
sported the more rigid and tough fabrics
great for storytelling but for ashley
not so much number four if you're gonna
eat do so at your own risk the worst
part about my costume was
i couldn't really eat
unfortunately this was a lesson simone
ashley learned the hard way it was her
first day of filming when ashley
realized that big meals and bridgeton
costumes were bigger rivals than the
featherington and bridgeton families the
actress had mentally prepped with a goal
in mind okay first day as a leading lady
gotta eat lots of food be really
energized if this were a different show
it's probably a pretty good plan but
when you're the star of a regency era
drama a beautiful and significant meal
of salmon hits the wrong way i realized
when you wear a corset you just don't
eat it changes your body i had a smaller
waist very momentarily my food was like
up here after the lunch break ashley
realized what a mistake she'd made while
she spent the rest of the afternoon
nauseous and on the verge of getting
sick for the rest of the day if she
didn't hate her corset before she
definitely did now
just
cool i am trying it is stuck
number five you do what you gotta do
everyone keeps their phones in their
boots in bridgeton don't tell you no one
can say the bridgeton costume crew
didn't make the outfits worn on the show
very historically accurate but it did
make for a modern day struggle
where to put the cell phone there were
no hidden pockets here so the actors
wearing boots did the best with what
they had now the boots themselves were
okay on their own but add a hard phone
rubbing against ankle bones and the
struggle becomes far worse bruised bones
anyone as for those actors who were in
heels well that was a whole other issue
and they had even less options of where
to tuck their phones away
number six heels on the bridgerton set
may cause the actor wearing them to fall
over just ask nicola coughlin she can
speak from experience on the first day
fell over three times in the heels
the actress fell over multiple times on
set in the first season and even with
all that practice she toppled over
filming in season two as well and she
was never doing particularly intense
things it could happen walking or just
standing trying to exist in the
uncomfortable and unstable shoes maybe
the worst harm she did cause in them
though was to on-screen bff eloise
bridgeton aka claudia jesse season one
saw the actress's heel accidentally
jabbing into jessie leaving the actress
bleeding on set they didn't fire me
thank goodness number seven this
princess curls were real
it's not a pub on the bridgerton set
this vibe count is known as
jonathan bailey the face of perms you do
what you gotta do for the job even if it
requires sitting to have your hair
treated for hours to spruce up its
curlitude oh and we can't forget the
sideburns that the actor grew himself
which have become more commonly known as
his lamb chops oh but the prep didn't
stop there
bailey had to get that hair primed and
prepped every day if bridgeton has
taught us anything it's that living in
the regency era is not easy
number eight this definitely wasn't part
of the style back then the season two
set of bridgerton included a new
accessory that's taken the globe by
storm over the past couple of years
it's covered now so we have we have
masks on so it's slightly different to
the first season while they removed them
on set when performing filming during a
particularly tough time the pandemic
meant masks were used often making it
even harder for the actors to breathe
who let's remember are already
struggling to breathe with those corsets
number nine only cool people wear capes
okay well these aren't exactly capes but
the actors were using coats and scarves
as if they were on top of everything
else they had to worry about every actor
on that set had to take extra care not
to spill anything on their outfits
meaning it was time to add more and more
layers whenever someone needed a snack
or pick-me-up coffee no action could be
taken until those costumes were
protected let's just say this wasn't a
help for the performers who already had
a tough enough time moving around the
set bulky and restrictive layers the
unfortunate bridger can cast reality
number 10 they don't wake up looking so
put together
they do wake up shockingly early though
nicola coughlin was up and ready to be
fetched by a driver at 4 45 a.m yes the
4 45 before the sun comes up there's a
lot of work to be done to transform this
into someone who's ready to go to a ball
in in regency london so yeah about two
hours the filming day couldn't begin
until the actress underwent her two-hour
hair and makeup transformation the
beauty expectation struggle is real
number eleven just how much pain is
beauty phoebe denivore knows the corset
and regency era costume drama well
especially considering she wore over a
hundred different dresses in the first
season each one of which contributed to
her unfortunate scabs and wounds all
over her back these injuries only got
worse until finally the actors could be
relieved of wearing the painful outfits
every day number 12.
let's crunch some numbers
season two of bridgerton did not hold
back first off the costume department
saw a whopping 7 500 pieces made from
scratch in just five months every
episode averaged a solid 90 costumes
while the second episode of season two
put them all to shame with its 146
handmade outfits with all this work it's
not too much of a surprise that the full
costume construction team was actually
composed of people from around the world
all of whom sent their work to the head
costume house in the uk once the pieces
arrived on set the head design team
checked over everything making sure
every detail was taken care of not a
ribbon was out of place and it shows
bridgerton never fails to be a feast for
the eyes
but not without causing the actors some
serious struggles their bodies are
thanking them every time they can rid
themselves of those restrictive pieces
what do you think would be the hardest
part about their regency era clothing